and I would not stop talking about my innocence
and the injustice and the betrayal and the deceipt,
until finally, just like this woman,
people were walking away from me,
until I finally realized
I wasn't just processing my feelings,
I was feeding them.
I didn't want to let that crucified self die.
But we all know that with any resurrection story,
you have to die first.
The Christian story,
Jesus was dead a whole day in the tomb
before he was resurrected.
And I believe that for us,
being in the tomb
means doing our own deep inner work
around our wounds
and allowing ourselves to be healed.
We have to let that crucified self die
so that a new self, a truer self,
is born.
We have to let that old story go
so that a new story, a truer story,
can be told.
Claim your experience. Don't let it claim you.
What if there were no survivors,
meaning, what if people decided
to just claim their trauma as an experience
instead of taking it on as an identity?
Maybe it would be the end of being
trapped in our wounds
and the beginning of amazing
self-exploration and discovery and growth.
Maybe it would be the start of defining ourselves
by who we have become
and who we are becoming.
So perhaps survivor was not
one of the three things that you would tell me.
No matter.
I just want you all to know that
I am really glad that we are on this bus together,
and this is my stop.
(Applause)